salut non c'est pas une référence à top
10 mais ça me fait bien rire comme nous
sommes en pleine semaine spéciale
micro-expressions n'oubliez pas que dans
la description il ya une crise qui vous
renvoie vers l'intégralité de ces vidéos
hier nous avons parlé ensemble de la
colère et bien aujourd'hui on va parler
de la surprise qui est sûrement la forme
d'étonnement la plus prononcée
génériques
pour voir les réactions de l'étonnement
au lieu de vous mettre un schéma ou quoi
que ce soit j'ai mieux qu'un schéma gels
et wahaha est à une particulière alité
entre autres léonard avec tout ce que tu
fais sur la chaîne télé vidéo réaction
oui et ça j'aime bien puisque forcément
pour les micro-expressions ça nous
intéresse mais là on va regarder ton
visage la surprise dure toujours moins
d'une seconde
bah en fait c'est ce que tu nous as dit
pour tout les micro-expressions dans le
principe oui mais la colère par exemple
qu'on a vu hier peut durer un petit peu
plus longtemps ça peut devenir même un
état mais la surprise par essence et une
réaction une réaction un style et
ensuite le visage cède la place à une
expression de trous alors à une autre
émotion quelque chose qui t'a énormément
étonnée quand la chanteuse loin de ma
folle aux as mais c'est où ça m'avait
quand david lafarge pokémon m'a dit
qu'il me connaissait
ça me fait super bizarre les signes
majeurs de la surprise ce sont donc les
sourcils qui ont remonté plus ou moins
légèrement t su faire un blizzard en
fonction de l'intensité de la surprise
en faisant cette tête bizarre vous venez
de voir le deuxième indicateur c'est la
bouche qui s'ouvre qui s'en trouve
légèrement ou alors qu'il souffre
énormément et bien sûr les yeux qui
s'écarquillent alors ne vous attendez
pas à voir ça les yeux qui
s'écarquillent comme ça au max est
beaucoup plus léger que ça
dans le livre des clones dont je vous
remets tous les jours de cette semaine
le lien dans la description il ya un
commentaire très intéressant si vous
voyez une expression de surprise qui
dure plus d'une seconde sur le visage de
quelqu'un alors c'est que cette surprise
là et simuler ses feuilletons importe la
raison d'ailleurs ce peut être pour
faire plaisir à l'autre face à un cadeau
ça peut être une exagération peu importe
pourquoi en tout cas si elle dure plus
d'une seconde ce n'est pas une réelle
surprise autre chose à savoir sur les
micro-expressions c'est qu'elles sont
toujours liés à des muscles en
particulier on va pas tous les nommés
ici mais ça veut dire que si la personne
en face de vous à une opération
chirurgicale une paralysie ou du botox
ce qui est de plus en plus fréquent vous
aurez beaucoup de mal à identifier les
micro-expressions parce que ça paralyse
aussi le muscle suivant le degré de
botox est même impossible pour vous
entraîner à voir exactement ce que donne
la surprise vous pouvez vous amuser à
passer pour un psychopathe commencé à
bien regarder les éléments clés donc les
yeux les sourcils et la bouche
et puis un moment donné sans prévenir
son corps a voulu hurler dessus
simplement vous verrez un recul
peut-être même les bras qui bouge ça
c'est une protection de base mais vous
verrez aussi tous les signes de la
surprise et peut-être de la peur et
ensuite de la colère au cours de cette
semaine je vous ai proposé de vous
concentrer sur des points clés par
rapport au visage et de la regarder du
coin
ainsi quand ils bougeront durant les un
quart de seconde vous y serez plus
sensibles je le répète avant d'analyser
il faut pouvoir détecter et c'est le but
de cette série alors pour continuer ce
qu'on a entamé hier concentrez vous donc
sur la bouche comme ça vous verrez les
pincements de la colère ou si elle s'en
trouve par la surprise sur les narines
toujours pour la colère sur les sourcils
également s qui se lève ou est-ce qu'ils
france vers le bas et vers le nez pour
la colère et les yeux d'un point de vue
écarquille mans on est toujours sur cet
axe l'un vous pouvez imaginer un petit
rectangle c'est plus facile à surveiller
que le visage en entier merci beaucoup à
leonardo s'est prêté au jeu pour cette
vidéo regardez les vidéos sur les vidéos
réaction en fait café léonard et vous
allez pouvoir voir les moments où il est
vraiment surpris avec ce qu'on a vu là
et on va faire une vidéo ensemble sur
nos chaînes de léonard un autre truc sur
des techniques de mentalisme au moment
vous regardez cette vidéo alors la vidéo
elle est sortie sur la chaîne de leoni
une fiche est si grave elle est là la
fiche ok mais elle est juste ici la
fiche et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
ici ou ici au mental blog c'est une
vidéo par jour depuis le 1er janvier
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao